I wanted to bring something up because
I've said this before now I'll say it
again and I'll stand behind it I think
we have the best fans in the world we do
I think they're coming I wasn't sure how
that would go over with you people I was
going out on a bit of a limb there but
I'm glad that it got the perception that
it did yeah anyway we have we have great
fans and one of the things that's great
about our fans are very passionate they
really pay attention well one eagle-eyed
fan who and this is true who goes by the
name of couch song has posted an
interesting video on YouTube and we'll
hear the highlights take a look I'd like
to start by saying I'm a huge Conan
O'Brien fan I always have been for a
very very long time I've been watching
the shows but I do notice something
about the new intro to the TBS show
Conan that really bothers me I am a bass
player and if you watch the intro to the
show it mentions Jimi Vivino and the
basic cable band and it shows the treble
clef where it's supposed to be and then
it shows the bass clef in the wrong
place on the staff I would think that
somebody would have noticed that could
you fix it gonna be great
Wow I have some other things first of
all when we show that right now there's
I'd like three people the audience over
there who when they saw with the bass
clef was just what it is so woodwind
chamber looks good
the other thing is I have when I for the
first time I saw that video when he
moves the camera over the side I thought
he was gonna show us his prisoner
it's scared really scared me
I think oh it's only the base huh first
of all how could this happen what's
wrong with you guys you're professional
musicians yeah let's keep a better eye
on the graphics guys yeah I mean that's
the bass clef that would seem that's
that's fairly elemental I would think in
the world of music
no one is okay Mike you play the bass
you have anything to say for yourself
well you don't watch this show do you no
not really
yeah
all right well fine defense you've made
for yourselves we want to make couch
song happy that's what I'm all about
so right now this is big-time television
we're gonna move the bass clef to its
proper position for all time what's
doing
[Applause]